Speaker 1: It is an increasingly difficult job for
the lawyers that have been hired, and I use the
term hired loosely because it's never really clear
that they're getting paid. The lawyers that have
been hired by Donald Trump to defend him and to
make the arguments in the court of public opinion
or in the media, that will really sway anybody.
Now, I've already said to you before the arguments
they make on TV, they often will not make in a
court of law. And we saw that over the last couple
of days. But sometimes it gets to the point where
they don't even really have arguments that they
can make on TV. And one of Donald Trump's lawyers,
Olina Haba, appeared yesterday on Newsmax and all
sorts of other media outlets, and nothing that
she said was particularly persuasive. One of the
claims she tried to make in this first clip is
that the reason Trump's buildings are worth so
much more than many will acknowledge is because
of the intangible value raising name recognition
that calling a building a Trump building has. Now,
unfortunately, this isn't true. But here's Elina
Harbor trying to make this argument, number one.
Speaker 5: Number two, when you have a Trump
property, that's a unicorn property, that's what
we call that. That's something that has a brand.
Speaker 1: That's what we
in the business call the.
Speaker 5: Value and has real estate value.
He's got some of the best buildings in New
York. So you want to sit there and tell me, Oh,
Trump, do you know what a property's worth? It's
worth what? Someone's willing to pay for it.
It doesn't matter what Letitia James thinks.
Speaker 1: Now, the only problem
with this argument is that Trump's
properties increasingly seem beleaguered
by being called Trump. Whatever. In fact,
remember some of these stories from when was this?
A From last year Trump branded New York building
looks to remove presidents name ex-presidents name
on tower reduces its value. This is the opposite
of the argument that Elina Harbor is making.
Other examples, Business Insider from 2019, all
the places that have removed Trump's name since he
won in 2016. And there's this whole list of places
to ice skating rinks removed. Trump signs. Nine
other buildings remove Trump sign. So it's just
a lie. In fact, not only might the Trump name not
increase value, it might diminish value. Here is
another one of these clips where it
just doesn't sound very convincing.
Speaker 5: Oh, be ready to grow
and we will continue to crush it.
Speaker 1: We're going to continue to crush it.
Speaker 5: It is what it is. It's an election
political ploy. Here we go, Leticia. You
know, you made a mistake. You wanted to file,
but it's going to be another all
in your bucket. Here we go. Yeah.
Speaker 1: I'm not finding her super credible
nor super persuasive. Here is the same lawyer,
Elina Haba, on a different show on I guess
this is also Newsmax. This one's called Rob
Schmitt tonight. And again, I'm not finding
her arguments particularly. I really think
persuasive is the right the right word.
Speaker 5: Now, the Department of Justice
filed this crazy raid, pretending it's
all these criminal actions because it's
around the corner to November.
And this is what we like to call
an October surprise, which we've seen before.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So it's an October surprise.
In September, before a November in which
Donald Trump is not actually running.
Hmm. It's not making a lot of sense, Alina. And,
of course, one of the realities that eventually we
just start to bump up against is you can't always
defend the indefensible. You just can't you get to
a certain point where. Okay, listen, you know
what? I don't know. I don't know. Between the
Mar-A-Lago thing and the Georgia thing and the
January six thing and the New York fraud thing
and all of the other things and the alleged rape
thing and all these. At some point, you just can't
keep continue. You can't continue defending the
indefensible. And that's what Trump's lawyers are
now up against. And it's quite a pleasure to
see. I have to tell you, hopefully they're at
least getting paid, which is a really tough thing
to collect when you are working for Donald Trump